[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello hello world good morning
we made it i was stressing out all night
yesterday trying to get into this thing
and i could not do it
but we're here now um i've turned down
the game volume
slightly might still be a little bit
loud i'm gonna crank it down
slightly a little bit more but yes
hello how's it going good morning and
welcome thanks for joining me
super excited to play i was seeing some
people in the chat talking about how
halos basically been their childhood and
i was sitting in my chair thinking i've
literally been playing halo for
over half of my life now as of this year
so pretty pretty wild um we've got
multiplayer against
bots and then we have academy where we
get to do weapon drills i did a couple
of drills already
because i wanted to make sure everything
was working but let me know
in the chat which guns you want to see
specifically i already tested out the vr
which was pretty dope
um i did all the trials on that one
sorry you guys missed it
i did a couple of other trials just to
try it out but
i also played one game of the
multiplayer to make sure we were all set
and smooth to go for the stream today so
yeah we are gonna get started
i'll start with a multiplayer match and
then in the chat
let me know which gun drills you might
want to see
maybe which guns specifically
you want me to try to test out on some
of the bots there's
a few interesting things i noticed so
far and even noticed from watching other
people play yesterday
was like grenades that are in the spawn
point where you can pick them up from
you can shoot them while they're in that
position and they'll explode so if you
like see someone running over there to
try and and get one
you might be able to shoot it and
explode it on them before they get it or
something
all right we're officially searching no
windows i would not like to update my pc
thank you
how to fix the bot slayer bug i'm not
sure
uh which bugs are really like persistent
right now considering i
just got in like this morning not too
long ago actually
like maybe an hour ago and i was like
yeah we get to play
so we will check it out
if you signed up for halo insider um you
should see an email
and or a message on your halo insert or
profile
if you um apply for it i guess
so yeah all good
i hope everyone is having a wonderful
morning hope you guys are excited to see
some halo
i'm excited oh whoa
i feel like my audio is all
wow that was interesting sorry i had to
fix the audio there no bots please
let me live i was trying to fix the
audio
so we do have sprint over there hostiles
and sights i feel like they'll hold
watch
out taking damage as well
there's the slide and i know a lot of
people are
not huge fans of the slide let's go
cool the bullets are plasma obviously
because it's a plasma
weapon so it kind of tracks to the
person and
the way that you burst it depends on how
the accuracy
[Music]
so yeah this weapon is interesting to me
at the moment
especially because you can vent which is
kind of like targets are over there
you can shoot right after you vent and
then or
you can even cancel the animation of
venting while you shoot
last week
trying to show an example
so if
pretty interesting to me i feel like
this weapon is gonna be
a sleeper people are gonna be sleeping
on it a bit
the audio is messed up
i know it does sound weird on my end too
like not all of the audio is actually
it sounded fine in my first match but
it does sound weird on my end as well
right now
different than earlier too
s7 sniper inbound like i only know that
you're over
[Music]
thing i'm terrified of that pulse rifle
now after i
played around with it over there
hostile's in sight
taking fire overshield
inbound oh my goodness yeah the audio is
bad right now
it's like progressively getting worse i
feel like i'm in
a tunnel or something overshield
available i can't even
killing spree
also notice when i was in firing range i
was getting a little bit
like on where i'm holding my gun too
but it seems to have cleared up already
so
oh i never saw you coming
wow i never saw that guy coming either
one thing i'm kind of missing right now
from halo 5
not exactly very haloy but
i appreciate this
actually oh moment will be remembered in
song
the commentary like in the game
no oh let's see
there are actually a ton of different
controller settings
if you want to change the look
sensitivities
one time scope to a sniper scope
you can specify all of those things too
spartan power items inbound
did some damage
[Music]
i'm playing button
um let me see if i can fix some of these
audio settings
in the game actually i don't know if
it's something i can fix or something
that the uh
let's get chat i'm sorry i couldn't like
look back
so let's see
[Music]
it's so weird actually because
i feel like that just started happening
did i change something in audio i didn't
realize it
i think we could turn these all down
i don't know what any of that does but
i'm like i had sort of messed
something up earlier i was just trying
to
change my pitch
[Music]
let me show you what i was talking about
and hopefully
game music and sound to loud voice too
song okay
let me try this how's this
i just feel like the game when the
actual game starts
that is so weird when the actual
match and i can see it in sorry i'm
looking at my screen because i can see
the uh
that's so weird the audio settings
change
a little bit 30 seconds remaining
in-game
versus lobby all right so this
gun is very interesting to me
because in theory he could just kill him
with two shots and then if you're like
going
and you've been and you could cancel the
animation and then like
forever and every
two one but yeah
i do not know why the audio is being
crazy right now
voice clipping slightly let me turn this
down
okay how about now i've adjusted
a few things
i actually should just keep going into a
match
because that's where the audio really
changes from the menu
stream audio was too high oh okay okay
so is this better
are we good now we good we thumbs up all
right
perfect perfect we're all perfect
everything everything's great
uh but yeah i feel like
it's funny story right let's travel back
in time
back i used to play halo 2 i used to
play on one sensitivity
now i play on like four-ish in
apex and on default this is on 4 and it
feels really slow
so we'll see
yeah so far the bots are like grenade
city which i guess is pretty good
because that's kind of probably how it
will be
um
the pistol is interesting so far because
i feel like it's in some weird middle
ground between
like halo 1 and halo 2. it has like this
fast fire rate and takes more than four
shots to kill somebody with it
but the reload time's really fast it's
pretty cool
why is this stuck now what
stop this stop
this let me in
let me in
did they take hovering out of the game i
have not really seen it
oh there we go okay phew wait who's laid
out on the floor
who's that on the floor what
was that one of our enemies he just met
his demise
that's so funny oh i'm gonna get psyched
out by those
all the time why aren't i covered
actually i want the br you know vr just
has a special place in my heart
yeah i'm right mess with my sensitivity
settings a little bit
after this
there's a little part of my like halo
muscle memory
that is like even though i've been
shooter-wise playing
just a ton of apex
try not to shoot your teammates in the
back of the head
oh hi oh no
thank you
[Music]
how far can i clamber okay not that far
keep your head down
nah look at my shield bro
you know about this shield bro
that's actually pretty silly
down a little bit
yeah oh no i tried to beat him down i
used to run
he freaking ninja me bro oh my god
i just got styled on by this spot it's
so
hard oh my god the distance back
no ow
okay it's fine you know we're just gonna
act like that never happened
active camo inbound
don't you do that to me yo mil i'm gonna
need you to take a breath
i'm gonna take a breath mel
he's doing too much he's doing too
much
bamboozled
where is the score oh it's down in the
bottom center okay
i'm like the ui layout feels so
clean but also my peripheral vision
doesn't exist
so
all right team you all are destroying
the bots way
too fast for me oh no how dare
you oh my gosh
that was bad
[Music]
one
oh
all right i got body right there it's
fine
one more kill team we got this
ah i almost had the last kill someone
else saw
it i call it so
it's a little cinematic too with the
intros and the outros
all right we got an overkill
i felt pretty good about that one
and i also got injured by the by the bot
but it's okay you know they're keeping
us on our toes
you know um
[Music]
16 and three
20 bombs only
now the whole technical preview for
at least this one i think i don't know
about future ones
because if you guys didn't watch the
preview where they explain more of it
this is only i think the first
the first like wave of previews that
they're gonna have
so if you haven't signed up for the halo
insider program
where they're kind of giving everyone
all the codes then you can still sign up
and get into one of the future ones
based on what they said and then you
know
even if you didn't get in now there's
still a chance you can get in later so
if you want to try that go for it
all right oh this is a new gun the
commando i want to try to use it
i just wanted to show the new gun
why you gotta be like this boss
um i actually don't know if the
difficulty of the bots like scales
based on how you're done oh this is so
far for me
i'm not gonna do that no it's gone
did he stay over yonder i'm so happy
oh thank you this uh
arena announcer is amazing he's
like such the hype man we all mean
um yeah so earlier i saw this shout out
to eric here for
showing me this if you shoot these in
the spot they blow up so if you like see
someone running over
to get no stop
oh my goodness you know something i'm
actually like getting stuck on right now
is um
in halo 5 you have like the little dash
which was super clutch
and dodging needs and now i keep
mentally trying to do it even though i
haven't
even played halo 5 in a really long time
it was just the last one that i had
played
he's hunting
oh yeah that was another cool thing they
changed
you can ah you can change the outline
of your teammates and your enemies i
might mess around with that too because
that actually
sounds pretty cool
um oh wait i wanted to use the commando
let me see if it's back
it's not back already
i
no too late okay
we'll follow him i don't think he'll die
to a lot but
if he does ow okay i'll just
out pistol me but
the slowest okay
commando so what i've
i use this gun in like one mission trial
so far
no i don't think machine guns suit me at
all i feel like i can't control it the
recoil's
a little more unwieldy than some of the
other guns
so what i was no he's behind me no he's
under me
maybe no the
radar are a little wide like
you know these bots do play like halo
players
hey little players definitely be
martyrdoming it up
throwing grenades on their dev it really
is like them
did some damage oh my god
should i shoot the enemy
okay commando is good when they jump
because then the recoil pattern pretty
much lines up with the jump bar
rose stop
it's always a little scary at the
beginning of a halo game learning like
how many shots can i eat plus a beat
down
before i r.i.p my life
come here
oh
whoa oh my god i can't see
yo dark star we keep running
yo yo cream corn
just destroyed me
yo kudos kudos cream corn
that humble pie was delicious
okay
oh my goodness all right the bots are
mad
the bots are coming back with the
vengeance
they may be down but they are not out
no they're out they're out we need two
kills we got this
one what a reliable one what a real
you know you're not wrong oh no
i knew it i saw it coming cream corn
again okay we dropped the 20 bomb this
time
you know we're not total disappointments
like the little cinematics
all right so i got to see the commando
let's see a little bit of the vr i think
the um
weapons are by team
is this a helmet why thank you
let's go again
is there buster in this and i've just
not seen it at all or what
like actually let me move my let me move
my coffee out of the way
of my screen i kept having to like lean
over to look
oh we are searching okay
yeah guys this is definitely a test
build
super early like we're not even playing
on the build that the devs are playing
on right now
that's like closer to launch so but i
think this is cool
they're like allowing us to join the
creative process
which is nice oh can i pick that one
down
no the audio is messed up again oh my
gosh what is happening
whoa whoa grab the active camera
this is um
my audio so some whoa some game whoa
what is happening
the audio all right so it must be like
certain games
the audio implodes and then sharing
games it doesn't
the other thing about this is that i
think they want people to like
submit like no stop stop oops
i can't hear anything it is devastating
and this bot is hunting me
whoa wait oh wait i'm so confused are we
both
are we all blue confusion raises
are we all blue
have we all always been blue and i just
didn't notice
i think that also might be the case
yeah the audio is totally bodied this
time
it's okay here this is um just
skills chaining right you
you hold back one of your senses like
ankle weights
active camo available i don't know it's
obtained
i got some some deployable shield
shields here oh wait
okay we go you can use two at once
pretty cool i'm hearing heavy breathing
very close to me
over yonder
i think that's my favorite call-out
it's like an olden time on my ex where
it like
seems like it gives the backyard where
did my grenade go
hello oh i'm i'm going away
i'm i'm going bye-bye
s7 sniper available
huh oh my goodness
i'm not i'm not very good with the
pistols
with the help from my entire team
holy moly
i can like hear the wind and like all
this ambient noise
i wonder if everyone else in the match
is also
hearing this oh no ellis with the nade
oh
oh my god vk 78 commando is ours
[Music]
i can't i can't let it happen yeah
that's right you better run
take cover oh my gosh i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding i was
joking nearing victory i was joking i
swear
everyone huddle up such beauty
i don't want it
the announcer though
wait that's teammate this is really
confusing
for my eyes i do know there's a little
icon above their head i should look for
that instead
of just looking at the color of the
camera
oh no i wasn't thinking
[Music]
oh my goodness
all right the audio was definitely a
little
a little lonely right there so hopefully
the next match will be okay
the match before that was actually
pretty good
yeah this is not even a demo this is
literally like the earliest of earliest
of previews
we're all lucky that they're inviting us
in general
and planning to invite more people
before launch
i think back in the day you know this
type of thing was unheard of
we would get a beta maybe but
like i feel like as
fans as players you know our voices are
heard even more now
than they ever were before so that's
kind of cool
but yeah let's see uh let's let's hope
for a regular audio match
that would be awesome
hmm so i think a few things i would
probably
sit down and look a little more at later
would be like
the ads sensitivity options because
there's a lot of different ones for each
like each range
oh i'm in the game
nope i'm a champion
all right eagle squad roll out
audio sounds good this ski this eight
braids yeah i think it sounds like a
mother
must be the best slayer that we could be
like an attitude positivity a little
circle
oh no this is like a spike sniper yeah
it's a teammate
or something oh wait i want to hit you
with purple
you know that box wasn't there
i might have better luck up close with
this thing personally
q is not melee
[Music]
no i missed that but they didn't chase
anyways
ah what happened
no yeah no
no
forge lord how could you do this to me
i was lagging camo inbound
pulse carbine obtained
pulse carbine brayden how
like
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
oh my goodness it's clogging my dreams
this is have nice things
[Music]
sorry we can't have nice things guys you
know i was down for the raid and
discussion
until
i don't even know who rayden was up
against right there but
oh wow the oldies
i see can not to deal with that shot
what is this again oh it's deployable
right yeah
cool
i don't know why i thought someone was
down there
for a row
nice you got it you got it good job
hmm i definitely think so far
one burst ruined my whole day
is it still in there oh he dropped right
yeah there is a hole
whoa get body that's what i get for
chasing scrub
guys number one rule in halo you don't
chase
learn lesson learnt
as the bots as the bot that kills me
killed me stands there and shoots
at a wall you know you know happy friday
you guys
happy party nice shield
thanks good job
oh yeah and the multiplayer is free to
play you're right you are totally right
chef
we look so cool everyone's just chilling
enjoying our bot victory
yeah i think the br is my favorite so
far
yeah that was my lowest kill game we go
again
i think is this the only map
yeah live
fire
but the weapons are rotating a little
bit kind of
i felt like we only had one game where
there was like a br in it
but yeah we can hop into some of the
weapon drills if you guys want to see
some weapon drills
and kind of see what more of the other
weapons look like
and yeah we could do that for sure just
let me know
i think so far weapons i haven't seen in
the multiplayer yet that are definitely
in the drills or like the shotgun
um
like some of the other spiky looking
weapons actually don't know what
i haven't seen needler on here either i
think
but yeah
we will try to find every gun most of
them
i'm likely not going to kill anybody
with them but
we get like a pr or something
then we should be good
let me end game
yeah we've lost a teammate oh my
goodness
you loaded in so late
so in this one when you sprint your
shields
will reload still like in halo 5 they
have that thing where
he doesn't know a mirror oh he's gone
got it got it he's gone gone
ah oh i have not used this gun yet
so ah okay so you use the ads
to change from like vertical to
horizontal
i think this is like a plasma shotgun
of some sort
um hello i need oh hey yeah
aim true spartan the heatwave
like ah a little bit
oh
it might not be as accurate to try it
bruce lightweights like that
but hey i actually thought the brute
shot was super cool back then
but you know
oh my goodness yeah
i probably shouldn't be using it from a
range like that but it's fine
oh wait i had a vr sad face
i missed thrust a little bit
a little bit
[Music]
yo the is need had cool sound effects
oh we have the spiker it's like
gunslinger i still don't
victory oh man
uh okay you know at least the watts
[Music]
oh no no i don't want to get ninja again
stop
stop
[Music]
[Music]
okay now you guys can approach
[Music]
he's oh i guess
victory
explosions
rtsd
power items incoming that moment where
everyone's just running to all the spawn
points
all right oh snap thanks for the carry
house
i think i think this feels pretty good
so far
when i was watching it like before i had
a chance to actually play it
i was like it didn't look like
the gunshots had like much
impact but now that i'm actually playing
it like it's a completely different
feeling than how it looks so
hopefully when everyone gets a chance to
play
[Music]
then you'll be able to truly see for
yourself how it feels
um i am playing on the xbox
series x
and honestly i have no idea what what
the fps is or anything
just being honest um so whatever the
default settings are
on the xbox is what we are running on
right now
i know a lot of people got into the like
steam pc
version of the um
of the out of the preview there's like
so
so many different things my brain wants
to call it alpha beta
no this technical preview
i will say it's like some things are
slower like
if you run slide it's definitely not
going to feel like
you know run slides in other games but i
think that fits
better with this type of shooter
probably because you know halo from
where it started oh dang you saw that
one too
my character means business um
got me a little hate like a lion called
the sniper oh
man you can't be too fat whoa
look blank push from behind
oh the deployable shield definitely has
a bit of a startup
we destroyed him before he even came up
i'm like i know by the time i run over
there they're probably going to destroy
everyone
so just come over here for the early
head start
i'm kind of trying to test this gun out
with like holding down auto fire or
bursting it i feel like it has its
place for both
but the recoil a little harder for me to
control
i kind of start with aiming for body
shots and let the recoil like take the
last
shot up to the headshot for me which
was kind of going okay in the weapon
drills but
i haven't really been able to try it
i just saw the red dot and turned around
had no idea whether it was going to be a
top or down
victory
sorry i stole your kill you know just
halo thing
i do it again oh okay all right i'm just
being trapped
it's called team shots it's called team
oops i don't know why i keep wanting to
press that button
someone
you definitely don't want to be caught
out in this game yeah not something
very reminiscent of the old days like at
least in a little vibe you could kind of
dip and weave and dodge and dash a
little bit so get off
it's gonna be impossible to get a sniper
i fell
just jump down there seeing them being
bullies
[Music]
inbound
oh my gosh dude
um i definitely tried to pull out a
shield bat
why am i like this brain i'm gonna need
you to adjust a little bit
faster all right brain
oh dang
learn something new every day i don't
know why it took me this video
let's make games figure that out
i actually want to try the grappling
hook
i feel like that's a huge thing i've
been wanting to
take a look at because
i don't know i feel like it's gonna be a
little game changing for halo
just in terms of like
cooler clips and stuff but i imagine
it's gonna be slower
kind of like the slide
you know i want to get my pal finder on
sometimes
it's okay guys i sent for master chief
too it's okay to admit it
[Laughter]
it's okay to admit it i'm having a great
time
you know it's spots yeah so it's like
you know not trying to be all halo pro
against no bots
but they do get you sometimes
i remember way back in the day when me
all my friends were playing attention
halo 3
was coming out and we're like yeah one
day
one day when we're all old
and we have like grandkids we're all
grandpa's and grandmas we're gonna be
playing halo 6 ha ha
look at us now right his reaction ain't
terrorist
exactly my vibe
the skewer
yeah the bots always rush like this path
over to that side i believe
i just want to shoot somebody with a
skewer
oh my goodness
wow
way
[Music]
okay i deserve to die kill me bye
[Music]
oh no the blue
these throws whoa these spots are fast
you'll think they're somewhere
targets
like to me i'm like wow these bots are
fast because every time i run to an area
that i know that they are
they're gone but in actuality it's like
if you're playing against someone
and they see you just as much as you saw
them they're like it's not probably oh
i'm an enemy territory
so they're like probably going to linger
around to try to catch you pushing it
right
i don't think there's team fire actually
or friendly fire
watch my back
this gun i feel like if a team
wanted to they could have someone who
runs like the plasma pulse
to destroy everyone's shields and then
the rest of the team can run
vr or something
a good burst though can't be a hail mary
burst into it where
all my teammates are too good
all the bots are underneath
nobody see anybody wagging around with
that oh
oh whoa oh those guys are coming in
hotel
no i can't use this pistol
okay i'm 90 sure there's no friendly
fire which is actually
great
i want this
oh
[Music]
foreign
ever since that one box would be dirty
terrified
absolutely terrified
don't like the new shotgun i actually
feel like do you mean the heatwave or
the
what was it called the bulldog or
something i
don't think i've tried the bulldog
actually
all right so well while that loads
let me mess around with some of my uh
oh sure is auto spin auto sprint would
be nice
i would probably interrupt or like mess
up some people
oh no i wasn't done yet
you know i was hoping to have a squad
uh but you know it's cool
i honestly it took me so long just to
get into this that
oh no
oh no the audio is messed up again it
feels bad
it's like in every other game type
situation
okay like one good audio game and one
not so good audio game
keep trying to holster my weapon
you're quite lethal with that
taking damage this song was fun
so weird i'm not even sure what type of
uh
oh and you know anybody else who's
playing in the preview like if you do
run into bugs like this
like they do want us to report it right
and i think they even have a thread
online
that says like the best practices on how
to report the bugs
like what you expect versus what
happened so like obviously we were like
uh we expected audio
and we got this instead overshoot
inbound
oh my goodness wait is this guy up over
here is that what the overshoot looks
like
interesting no he's
i feel like the audio clips are a little
more
funny and oh
[Music]
have weight of victory
no no no
we needed each other let's this is
this is halo this is definitely halo
is that you oh
oh i see i see we have a shield now
we just ran no
i don't think the beatdown range is as
generous as it used to be
back in the day either
yard sale oh there's a sniper there
oh shoot
overshield inbound
what overshield available
bro did i not hit him i could have swore
actually
hit that guy no you're kinda you're so
you're so tactically positioned my dude
killing
yeah thanks for the backup teammate
yeah that was tactically positioned
behind that shield
oh bad no i keep trying to beat down
with left bumper
that is not that is not
what i'm supposed to be doing i mean
right bumper i keep deploying the shield
right
yeah that's one heartbeat take cover
hello hello
did some damage
oh wait is that my teammate no it's not
oh no massive need
nice shot marmot
all right and then i think the only
major bug we've run into sobriety is
this audio one
so i'm not sure what kind of bugs other
people have run into so far
but i think that this is definitely the
only big one
i've seen to run into
um
the battle pass
oh yeah they gave us a bunch of free
currency so that we could like unlock
stuff and test how their mark their
little like in-game market works
so i did not put any funds into this
just so you guys know i know my
sensitivity
does feel slow it definitely does feel
slope
it's already on four which is shocking
to me and i think like
i think the normal ads feels also and
then the i mean
like normal view feels nice so in the
abs feels a little fast
i got to do some fine tuning but that
stuff takes a while and i don't really
feel like doing it like
all right live so i'm like let's just
roll with it i might bump it up to like
five though
actually earn more
[Music]
okay
all right get wrecked
i know they did say at some point this
week and they were going to put some
really tough bots into the game
but i think that's not until later this
weekend like on sunday or something
oh my goodness i feel like i have to be
very close
good
[Music]
xbox noises
[Music]
um hello
they're under always underneath
wow that guy's that guy's body was yeah
my sensitivity is
way too slow
whoa i'm getting a weird screen flashing
overshield inbound
did that change at all
holy all needs
all the time did it actually say
that uh is the question
yeah it did okay it didn't feel like it
changed much
at all
i like all the names of the bots power
controller
pretty good i wonder if they're named
after like that's one team or something
or just random names
like it's a black one if you just want
to
oh
and yeah i still think vr is my favorite
gun so far
in all honesty but
that's probably at least 50 percent
nostalgia
but also just a really good gun
but grenades was like jumping into the
wrong place for the grenade this is
definitely halo y'all
that's what halo 5 was called
no is there someone by me there he is
please
please maybe nellie's chasing why are
you thinking
okay whoa he didn't die shenanigans
i call shenanigans from that
yo
the face off of like watching the bot
reload
and getting gunned down humans
nearing victory
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know guys i like this game a lot
i think it's pretty fun
and it feels pretty again
hmm
oh no okay yeah
i might need to burst this gun
the longer i just like spray and pray
with the commando the more it's just
like
[Music]
all over the place
i also can't wait until
the full game just to see like if this
is what it is now
like early builds imagine how it's gonna
on lunch i'm enjoying it so far
it also just feels very classic too
there's like even though there is sprint
and slide
i mean i haven't tried the grapple yet
but
even though there's all that it still
feels very haloy
in terms of you know olga halo's the
movement was never really that great
to begin with like you really just
relied on
your gun skill and your accuracy
which is something i feel i can tell
like playing apex for so long how much
more i rely on like running around
and like angling to get like better
shots and like
kiting people basically and doing a
little damage over time and so like
they go down while trying to chase me
compared to like
this or it's like nah get your accuracy
up bro
yes you can slide it's very slow though
it's very slow
oh geez my matches have been starting
pretty sluggishly as well
like oh oh wait i think i i joined in
the middle of a match
overshield available so yeah the slide
there you go it's like it's cool
i should keep
wait i didn't take damage okay no
friendly fire for sure
all right now no holds bart right like
throw all the names even if i see my
teammates
oh targets are over there
ow oh no not owl no friendly fire
this guy's
watch my back watch my back
oh man oh why why am i
this i have no control
i have no control that's the way i've
ever ever come watch my back
it's intense
come here robots
robots oh no
wait i'm trying to overshield available
oh did i
that's not the one i dropped right oh it
did register
it looked like i clambered and the
clamber like canceled the animation
there's a cooldown between you when you
use both
killing spree he was low already
oh needler i haven't pleased
all right this round had all the good
all the good test weapons
very neat lurie this gun's so cool
you've lost a teammate
oh i forgot to have that
just shoddy things keep your head down
right now all i hear is intense ambient
music
it's okay i have a radar
you're gonna take a weapon where did
they get the needle
from i want to pick up a fresh one
all right well unfortunately we joined
halfway through that match so
but it's fine
yeah i feel like halo 5 might have been
like
too much out of the halo box for some
players like i'm not going to say for
all players but for some players because
i know some of the biggest complaints i
heard about that game was just
all the extra mechanics but i felt like
they kind of mixed that
with like the older halos and this one
and kind of
brought it closer to its roots i mean
besides halo 2
multiplayer halo 5 multiplayer is like
my second favorite
so this almost feels like a mix between
both of them
which is kind of cool
but also has shown me like
how much differently i play than when i
used to
to be all about the like you know i get
my aim on luck
you know i've got to be laser sight and
then
you play other games you're like gotta
get my movement up
can't die if they can't hit me right
but yeah it's it's been a good time
so far though
all right nice okay we got a full
uh early match i mean a full match
starting from the start
have i had issues loading a new game
after a game ends
there's been a few times where like when
a new game loads
um the audio doesn't work but i haven't
really had
issues actually starting up another
match so
that sounds interesting like an
interesting issue
but yeah anybody else who's playing make
sure you're drawing this is so funny to
me that there's just like a random body
on the floor
there's more kills than your phone i
can't even tell if that's like our
teammate or
like oh i forgot they all come
[Music]
bed
watch what happens next game i'm gonna
overkill one of them fishing that's like
oh
ow my shields
got obliterated please don't skewer me
[Music]
bro
so
[Music]
available
reloading
let's go get a new vr i've run out of
ammo
there's someone over here going
underneath
it's okay
[Laughter]
oh
i just had some fresh beer i was trying
to get the angle
you know i feel like i would end up
being the type of person who's trying to
take like a nice picture and
accidentally falling off like the side
of a ledge
and like breaking my leg or something i
feel like that would
be something that would happen to me
based on
okay question question mark
i like the way it sounds
inbound
my sensitivity still feels low and it's
on five and that
that's uh probably like the highest
sensitivity i've ever used to be honest
my goodness y'all got this vr unlock
over here don't you wait
there it is there it is
you're quite lethal with that
they did it they blew me up with the
grenades and
no you you
me face
okay had to think about dying real quick
and then he did
we take those
he's hearing such actions
whoa whoa all right scoreboard
take a breather scoreboard was
tripping out for a moment
i am honestly having way too much fun
right now
i feel like it's been so long
since i've just sat down played some
halo
and now it's like halo halo's popping
again
everyone wants to play everyone's
excited talking about it you know
there's always that that golden time
playing halo and everyone else's and
everyone's excited again makes me feel
like i'm 13
all over again
way back in the day
all right another full match we've been
we've been doing pretty good now
we're loading in let's see if the audio
loads and
loads in fine see we get the early
cinematics of where all the power
weapons are
i mean yeah it's bots but you still get
a chance to
get a feel for the gun and how to use it
and
learn the maps
and when you play against other people
obviously
players are just so amazingly good
that it's hard to learn anything because
you get obliterated
and arguably this is a little more fun
than
trying to learn all this stuff in the
weapon drills and i feel like the weapon
drills are going to be a little more fun
for
trying to do speed runs and like you
know leaderboard stats and stuff
which it's also fun in its own way
oh boy all right let's separate with the
commando a little bit more
i will learn to control the camera
the pops are like chilling over here
i wonder if they have a special
waistline
for skewering someone
i don't like ads with this thing
although it does have like a decent
abs range also like as if a rifle like
yeah i need to mess with some of these
80s
i'm so sorry teami i feel like i
contributed to that
oh wow yeah after a few seconds
i can no longer i'm gonna try to tap it
instead of spraying with it
i think up close i might get away with
spraying it
a little more far away not so much
but that sounds about right it's like an
oddly quiet game like the bots are
running around pretty slowly
active camo inbound
[Music]
natural draining like meter
oh wait i gotta try this
oh no i didn't want to kill you
oh no okay let's find the wall
see i like how the shield works
like you can break the panels you can
walk through it
this side can shoot through this i can't
but you can break the panel so
i think that's not as bad
personally oh hi you're not on my feet
miss a point blank no i deserve to die
you got a teammate yeah
this definitely does not have like the
walk on bowers that
uh it once had in its previous days or
maybe it doesn't i was just missing so
hard that it's alright let's try again
let's get a little
okay well you can't like
because before you could do it like a
little bit further away from someone
and it would like totally curve around
the world
and get you wait no i need
people to sign up
be proud be proud spartan
this announcer is so wholesome active
camo inbound
all right i'm gonna try to just shoot it
active camo available
is styling on us right now
okay this game's been super quiet
[Music]
you know it's proven scientific fact
that if you lean irl you will lean
further in the game
i don't make their own government
it is just
oh
are you just having fun
power items incoming
every time i'm like i'm gonna try to
burst fire this gun i never do i
immediately just start spraying and it
just goes all over the place
all right definitely the slowest game
we've had so far somehow
oh okay because there's only two
bots i was like this match is definitely
really slow and it makes it makes sense
now
it makes sense now hello friends how's
it going
nice gun very purple oh oh yeah i forgot
you can like drop them
toxic
we were we were having a bonding sharing
weapons
moments like true teammates
five minutes remaining
[Music]
a little bit of burst action instead of
just
spray and pray yeah okay i was
definitely like
oh my goodness so slow
but then there's only two bots in here
it all makes sense now
it's like i attempted to jump and then
[Music]
when i got shot like running back down
to the ground or something i don't know
that was weird
active camel available
try to get the camera
how dare you see me as i am activating
my camo
i'm not supposed to be stealthy
oh when you run okay it makes sense
run you are less stealthy
you can't see oh it's
not the be down button that's that's
that's not the beat down button
oh double shield counter
right now belly shields
oh man i kind of definitely want to see
how all this goes down in
real 4v4 multiplayer skewer available
all right we finally made it through we
made it
um
but yeah
let's try to get a match with all of our
enemy bots i mean i get it we're pretty
intimidating
you know
let me assume
but i think
close
i think this game is definitely going to
appeal more into just like
long time halo fans and
it's free to play so then ultimately
anybody who just wants to give it a shot
will be able to give it a shot
once it's out so
i am playing on the xbox series x
on console you know like a true
halo player playing it on console
i don't think i ever imagined like back
in the day that
you know halo would end up launching on
pc and stuff
but yeah i was watching snipe down play
a bit of this yesterday on his stream
it's pretty cool like definitely a blast
from the past like what year is it
i'm watching snipe down play the new
halo game
i feel like when it takes a while to
load at the start like this
is when i get put into like a match
that's already in progress
so we can test that theory once it
happens
yeah free to play multiplayer
definitely gonna be interesting
i mean i appreciate all the people in
chat
actually chilling and having a nice
friday a stress-free friday
um i think we're stuck in loading screen
now but
but i will say since i couldn't get my
like build to work yesterday that
watching it feels way different than
playing it
i will say that i kind of had a
different idea of
how i thought it was going to feel when
i played it but
it's it's not quite like that i did not
find grappling hook yet i need to run
around more to the uh
power-up areas because i think i have a
general grasp of where they spawn now
but so far i've just
picked up the deployable shields
yes it is friday you guys
take a breather we're chilling
we're shooting some guns
and just you know trying to save the few
brain cells we have left
some of you in chat are not helping with
that but it's okay we still love you and
care about you anyways
oh it looks like we're stuck in the void
at the moment last time we were stuck on
this loading screen for a little while
but it did pull through eventually
but this is so far the longest loading
time we've had
okay i was returned a lot because of
inactivity
i mean that's one way to send me back i
suppose they're not wrong
i wasn't doing anything actually so
true i guess
[Laughter]
well you guys if your brain cells are
fried we've got
you know a nice weekend ahead of us
couple days
to take a deep breath a little woo saw
a little relaxation
and uh for those of you in the preview a
little bit of halo
you know yeah no
i mean think about it guys if we were
not playing against spots
this would probably be 50 million more
times
difficult to pull off
than just running all like regular
players right
am indeed on xbox series x
for those asking
you know you gotta play halo on console
you know
oh don't worry these bots these spots
are done
for all right we're gonna wait a moment
here and then we're gonna throw this
there
i was too early i was really my life
no i was so greedy for the triple
and i died for it a teammate
care about us
i think
killed him at my last shot
i do that way too much
overshield inbound available
moment
i mean i can at least see that like in a
real match i
would not be getting away with like half
of the stuff
like what happened to that i was super
low and the bot was just like i'll just
shoot this other person now
hey i'll take those for sure
but grenades are already
don't explode myself put that spiker
[Music]
nibs
s7 sniper available a sniper
let's pick it up so we can miss
everything watch out bro i need it
no yeah no too slow
oh he's just straight up
trying really hard to control that
[Music]
all right let's see
singular bullet on some that
haunting him
okay i
don't think the commandos my type of
weapons
trying to live my life
you can ads but the ads is not that
great
with commando it's already very
unwieldy and adsing with it does not
make it any better
like some weapons kind of doesn't
make much of a difference yes
i mean you have a scope right there on
your screen in the center
use it
i haven't played halo in 12 years phew
well halo infinite multiplayer is
gonna be free to play
all right 18 girls we've only had 120
bomb today unfortunately
i want to get 20 bombs every game it's
okay
we'll get back up on that on that status
soon
i think in future tech tests they were
planning on maybe doing some more
like pvp related things and having more
people invited
so if you guys have not signed up for
halo insider you still have a chance
to sign up for it and like you still
have a chance to like get into a future
one so
just because this one's going on and you
didn't sign up for before
there's still a chance to play in the
future so sign up anyways you never know
you never know
yeah the halo 2 pistol is not that great
but if you dual wielded it with
something it was pretty good
oh there we go
one bot literally just turned around
shooting in the air
no this is horrible wait don't kill me
that i just got this vr
oh no
grenades hurts a loss
ouch
extreme pain
[Music]
oh did not have a good angle
uh oh wait is the spawn back yet
they are still my favorite
it feels so good to use the vr
you can still four shot people too but
it seems a little bit
more tight
[Music]
that's also where i like to use the
thrusts like dash from halo 5
when you're one shot someone else shows
up
and you're like uh i kind of need to
dash and
maybe hopefully they'll miss a shot or
two and i can
turn it around
[Music]
little jumps we can learn too eventually
i'm sure on all the other maps it was
going to be
skewer jumps that you need to make like
oh my gosh the amount of times i fell
off the map trying to make certain jumps
and when you're adapting and you get and
you take damage it knocks you out of the
eds so
that's something else keep in mind when
you're playing this it's not like
other games where you're allowed to stay
in abs even though you're taking damage
at least that's how it's been so far
you're quite lethal with that
please die
the bots are super good with the pistols
and then when i use it i'm like
i don't know about all that
i wouldn't say they're like
whoa he came out of nowhere without you
down
thanks save my life
it really still does like another one
confusing a little bit that both of our
teams are the same color
i guess i have to change that manually
[Music]
10 million shots later
come on dude i know you see me on your
radar
[Music]
see that's what make those little
moments right there if you're fighting a
human
and you're getting shot in the back they
would take that moment of hesitation to
like stop or turn around
and then you'd kill him but the box like
nah
i've read it for my life we're out of
there
chase me at your own risk
i appreciate those it like lets me know
how much i take for granted
it's been a good time so far though
um you know what i keep forgetting to
look for while i'm out there
it's the grappling hook i don't know if
it's even in the build but it is
something i keep forgetting to look for
all right i'm gonna try to look for the
grappling hook see if it's out there
try bunny hopping i mean that's
never really
been that great unless i'm using bumper
jumper but even then when i use bumper
jumper
i don't bunny hop i would just
strafe and then at the end of the fight
i would go for a jump
to disrupt like the
the line of sight but i feel like
personally
i've never been like oh bunny hopping is
supreme in halo
in other games heck yeah bunny hop all
day
and halo though i don't know i don't
know about all that
um my sensitivity is on like five
my dead zone look and stuff like that
and like lick acceleration i haven't
really messed with it i did change like
one setting
that i'm retrospectively kind of like
maybe this isn't
what it should be getting on visual
things like this one
was on two but i was i don't usually
like playing with it on
but maybe that's why it feels a little
weird i don't know there's a little a
lot of settings and i usually get scared
to adjust
them too much from the default because
this is like first two hours of playing
the game
like how am i really gonna know the
defaults not for me
if i don't try it and at least like try
to feel it out a little bit
but i don't know
all right let's see if we can do this
now
we could just get the whole team to
throw knees there
snipers would be good
oh my goodness oh my god
the grenade
grenades are bonkers
grenades
oh they're all over here
oh my god
give me battle rifle that
[Music]
i was like gonna try to go for the beat
down but i knew in my head
that i was not gonna get the lunge so i
was like do i really want to go for this
b sound right now
the answer was no and i died for it so
it is what it is
so i think so far something i would like
to see is this is like
auto sprint only because
i use it in apex and it definitely saves
me a lot of bandwidth on my controller
like when you're in the middle of the
gunfight and you see the bot just like
offer a nade
it's like all right you're over with
that time he just straight up body
that's exactly like how people play
though y'all can't act like these bots
aren't at least a little bit reminiscent
of halo players we've seen
in our lives because i do feel like
their movements and stuff aren't
very assembling without people obviously
not 100
but certain things like you know you get
caught out
and thrown in that's usually what people
do sometimes
i think they did mention like the bots
do emulate
a lot of human behavior type thing too
you know they're evolving i'm honestly
shook to see what like the pro level
bots are gonna be like
nearing victory we ain't ready for all
that
overshield available
oh
cover me
oh my goodness no i knew that one was
behind me
but i was hoping it would target my
teammate
instead of me oh that didn't work
it's fine
[Applause]
how and then oh my god
oh my it's a battlefield out here
explosions everywhere
these needs are terrifying
guys
i know i don't want to think about the
higher level bus
i don't not until i learn how to not get
caught by you need 35 seconds
oh in progress this is a first
usually it's ready to play like right
when we come back
but not this time
question mark
yo what's good
i think i see david in here hold up
hold up
we've got david ahmadi in the group
i think it's crossplay because his build
is on pc
my build's on
xbox
now it's not loading though i guess this
is a good test
seeing if we can get um
somebody into the party
rashby down in the bottom right wait no
i lost connection to the server
that's
let's unfortunate if we can get back in
there
or is the server on break or something i
feel like i vaguely remember reading
time slots but i could be
i could be wrong i'm in we played
we got a lot of matches in there we got
some good ones we got some
mediocre ones but overall is a good sign
yeah we might be having some
server issues now
unfortunately
but we played quite a few matches i mean
we've been live for like a little over
two hours so
ah i see i see yeah that might be
that might be the case i do remember
reading that there was some time slots
like per day i just didn't um i was too
stressed out trying to get my build to
work but i was like oh look at that
later
so it's possible the time slot for this
morning has come to a close
so that means our stream
might have to also come through those
but i see some people asking about
customization which is
a good idea i don't know how to do it
actually but i know it's possible
so let me let me look around
a little no
season progress settings
ooh
interesting guess what the
challenges are gonna look like
um let's see let's go ah there it is
it's back on this menu
armor hall
this is just the straight up regular one
all right armor kit coding
is ah the colors
nice i guess we don't have thumbnails
there but you can see those colors
it's a nice color
oh i guess it shows the rarity here gold
colors
what do we think about these i don't
know if it's a legendary
oh you think it was the first
legendaries i actually don't know if any
of this
stuff with this battle pass in this
preview is actually going to be what the
battle pass looks like because i think
it's all for testing purposes
but some of these look pretty cool
i wonder what's like really
differentiating these
from it's not like in other games the
legendary skins like
have animated effects or something
let's see what else we got got some
helmets oh yeah i obtained
a rare helmet quote-unquote which one
was it was it this one
oh yeah blue is rare
purple's epic
i'll equip it why not it's new
oh different color visors
i like that one epic visor
vandal i'm just going to equip the
things i unlock already just
because i have them
you know let's put some armor on our
armor guys
i'll feel good about that my armor plate
right there
it needs more armor
oh oh i don't have any new shoulder pads
but
let's take a look at some shoulder
some bags one glove only one glove
with the hips yeah you gotta make sure
customize those hips
got the knee pads
why is my armor so dirty i need
to clean the armor um
so yeah that's what we got in our
general settings here
and then i think most like these
coatings or stuff are going to be what
you need so
i wonder if you can actually
optimize i
oh i mean yeah probably the legendaries
and stuff right
all right well weapons bench
oh that's right because you can put
skins on your weapons now
or at least color them which is you know
personally i like customizing my guns i
feel like it makes me
shoot better if it looks cuter
body and ai oh snap
i see
oh cool
very cute definitely in the pink one
i quit
i like this all right
presentation oh customize your emblem
announcer voice service tag etc
but that is not available at the moment
can't click on it
all right guys well i think we
have done all we can do today i think
the service is closed for this time slot
but they'll be open again
uh you know throughout the next few days
i had an awesome time
um obviously it's halo
you know and it feels it feels like halo
but
playing all these other games recently
definitely makes it feel different
so i'm curious and excited to play some
more
and you know get good again
right halo used to be my main game but i
definitely did not play with luxury
but we kicked it off with an overkill
and that's pretty dope
so i had a great time i hope everybody
else had a great time
if you're in uh you know the preview
enjoy report those bugs maybe let's run
some matches for everybody else who's
not in it it's not too late to sign up
they're gonna have more previews
in the future before launch so you can
still sign up go to halo waypoint
and sign up for the halo insider stuff
to try to get into the next one
but yeah thank you so much i'll see you
guys later and
bye bye happy friday see yah
you